be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so with Suicide Squad coming out this
week in addition to the various
character discussions what I wanted to
do here is offer some videos on
different aspects of the Joker and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of all
this you'll have a good idea of how all
these concepts come together in a way
that provides a well-rounded discussion
about his character so in terms of the
Joker's origin DC has actually provided
a litany of stories from different
writers over the years and while some of
these tie-in to previous stories others
are entirely self-contained with no
reliance on existing content jump me
back to 1951 with Detective Comics issue
number 168 Batman co-creator Bill Finger
offered the Joker's first origin in the
story titled the man behind the Red Hood
centering on Batman and Dick Grayson
hosting a special segment on criminology
at state university the two focus on the
case of the Red Hood one which was never
solved due to Batman and Robin trying
the Red Hood down to ace chemicals who
in turn jumped into a vat and escaped
where the story would see the students
in the class reopening the case and
prompting the Red Hood to come out of
retirement the events transformed into a
chance for Batman and Dick Grayson to
discover the identity of the Red Hood
himself engaging in a cat-and-mouse game
after Red Hood broke into and robbed the
campus payroll office the story saw the
identity of the Red Hood to be a man
named Earl Benson who was actually an
imposter as it was explained the robbery
of the payroll office was performed by
the real Red Hood but following this act
Earl Benson captured the Red Hood stole
his uniform and engaged in a series of
ancillary robberies with the intention
of using the identity to escape without
being discovered
forcing Earl to bring them to the
location of where the original Red Hood
was held captive the store revealed that
the Joker himself was the original Red
Hood and operated as a criminal while an
oxygen tank concealed inside the hood
allowed the Joker to survive his
exposure to the VAT of chemicals
transformed his physical appearance and
in turn he decided to use his physical
form to both terrify people and commit
crimes christening himself the Joker as
a tribute to ace chemicals now following
this the next iteration of the Joker's
origin and commonly considered to be the
most definitive story came in 1988 with
The Killing Joke by Alan Moore
Count Eliezer on the work of Bill Finger
in Detective Comics 168 The Killing Joke
provided the events leading up to the
Joker jumping into the bat by explaining
that the Joker himself had been a
chemical engineer working for ace
chemicals but quit his day job in an
effort to become a stand-up comedian
failing in this endeavor but recognizing
the responsibility that came with
supporting his wife Jeanne and her
unborn child The Joker found himself
tumbling down the rabbit hole and into a
business with two criminals who looked
to rob a skinner khals providing the
Joker with the Red Hood identity in the
story revealed that the two criminals
were actually a team and had been doing
individuals into helping them with
crimes pawning this scheme off on the
accomplice by claiming that the Red Hood
was the leader finding himself in the
same situation where Joker attempted to
back out due to his responsibilities as
a husband and eventual father after
discovering that his wife and unborn
child were killed and during the robbery
of a Skinner Coles in subsequent fall
into the VAT of chemicals the Joker's
personal struggles as a failed comedian
the loss of his family and the physical
transformation he sustained from
exposure to the chemicals all came
together driving him insane and creating
the version of the Joker that we know
today now following this between 1988
and the current day most all of the
Joker's origins haven't some former
fashion drawn on the information
established within the pages of The
Killing Joke either expanding on the
information offered by Alan Moore or
else changing things up a bit as an
example in 2004 as part of the Gotham
Knight series a monthly line of comics
designed to focus on Batman's extended
cast including Alfred Batgirl and others
but ended up focusing on his villains
the five-part story push-back written by
AJ Lee Berman established that during
the events of Killing Joke the Joker's
name was Jack and his wife had been
murdered by a police officer who had
been paid off by the mobsters in
addition to this within the pages of
Batman black-and-white writer Paul Dini
and artist Alex Ross came together for a
short story titled case study which saw
psychiatrists analyzing old interviews
from both doctors and Colonels who had
worked alongside and examined the Joker
using this as a frame of reference case
study offered the possibility that the
Joker was actually completely sane and
used the guise of the Joker's insanity
to avoid execution for his crimes as
well as maintaining his role as a
criminal within Gotham using his
frequent interviews with various
psychologists to promote the perception
of insanity by offering different pasts
to different people
furthermore writers have also focused on
the childhood of Joker providing both
detailed and veiled allusions to his
life prior to the Killing Joke covered
in Paul Dinis 2009 series Batman streets
of Gotham which focus on the concept of
Batman but from the perspective of both
criminals and civilians on the
street-level the house of hush storyline
offered the idea that the Joker had
previously been a boy named Sonny who
was cared for by Thomas and Martha Wayne
before being kidnapped and sexually
assaulted by a mobster named Sally guzo
as part of the new 52 writer Andy Kubert
wrote Batman issue 23.1 designed to be a
one-shot focusing on the Joker himself
following his reintroduction to the new
52 with death of the family while it's
only covered in a few pages The Joker
flashes back to his childhood where he
was cared for by his abusive aunt who
looked to force Joker to give up his
attachment to his stuffed animal by
scrubbing his skin with bleach and
bragging about how she murdered the
Joker's uncle by way of a Colombian
necktie now following this and under the
writing of Scott Snyder as part of the
new 52 the convoluted history of the
yogas origin saw a wholesale revamp
using both previous themes and creating
wholly new content building on a concept
of the Red Hood Snyder established that
where the Joker had previously used his
moniker during his early days as a
criminal leading to his exposure to the
bat of chemicals during the events of
endgame which came as sliders planned
conclusion to the Batman epic designed
to put the caped crusader against the
Joker the work of Snyder modified the
Lazarus pits of DC Comics to not only be
a source of immortality for Ra's al Ghul
and Vandal Savage but to also be a
source of immortality for the Joker
describing the Joker as the pale man who
encountered the pits
prior to his rise in Gotham the Joker
spent most of his time in Gotham proper
orchestrating a series of grisly crimes
and murders while the purpose behind
this origin was to depict the Joker and
Batman as the dichotomy of an
unstoppable force meeting an immovable
object the ending of endgame was
presumed to kill off the Joker allowing
Snyder to bribe Bruce Wayne out of the
comic temporarily in an effort to make
way for Jim Gordon to take over the role
having said that is part of Darkseid war
and going into the launch of DC rebirth
which serves to return DC Comics
to its classical story-driven roots
using both recognizable and new content
the origin of the Joker appears to be in
the midst of a revamp yet again by
Batman learning that instead of one
Joker there's actually three however
because the story arc still being
fleshed out albeit at an extremely slow
rate there is no information in
existence at the moment as to who these
Joker's might be or where they came from
but that being said we're going to wrap
this up and just out of curiosity if you
guys have your own theories on who you
think the three Joker's are or what time
period they come from
post a comment down and let me know and
I'll pick the best three and I'll
actually do a video on those later on
this week and I will catch you guys
later peace